für mich ganz kurzfristig wird der
Bundestag hier eine Aktuelle Stunde
aufsetzen zum Thema gasumlage die
cdu/csu-fraktion hatte das verlangt und
zwar relativ kurzfristig aus der
Fragestunde die hier in den letzten
Antwort ungefähr 70 Minuten lief im
Deutschen Bundestag da hat der
Parlamentarische Staatssekretär aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium Michael Kellner
Fragen beantwortet der Abgeordneten und
die Unionsfraktion fand dass diese
Fragen ausweichen bzw nicht genau genug
beantwortet worden sind gerade zu dem
umstrittenen Thema gasumlage deswegen
also jetzt die Aktuelle Stunde zunächst
jetzt mit einem Redner der Union Andreas
will ich ihnen nicht widersprechen
sondern jetzt gerne sprechen und möchte
doch vorneweg nach den Aufgeregtheiten
die ist gerade gegeben hat darauf
hinweisen dass wir hier nicht etwa
parlamentsrechtsgeschichte schreiben
sondern es ein völlig normaler Vorgang
ist
das einer solchen Befragung sich eine
Aktuelle Stunde entwickelt die Aktuelle
Stunde ist aktuelle Stunde was ich mit
aktuellen Fragen beschäftigt
und
offenkundig haben wir Gesprächsbedarf
zur gasumlage wir melden den seit vielen
Wochen an aber der hat mit dem heutigen
Tag eine neue Qualität bekommen heute
haben sie Herr Minister Habig mitgeteilt
dass Juniper verstaatlicht werden soll
und es verändert die Geschäftsgrundlage
für die Bewertung der gasumlage noch
einmal mehr wir haben wir haben Herr
Kollege wir haben selbstverständlich
nach der gasumlage gefragt wir haben die
gasumlage thematisiert wir werden morgen
die Aufhebung der gasumlage im
namentlicher Abstimmung betragen und das
haben wir bereits vor der Ankündigung
der Verstaatlichung gemacht aber mit der
Verstaatlichung ist erst recht klar
diese gasumlage muss weg
sie
sie war von vornherein völlig falsch
aufgekleist sie ist in der Umsetzung
total verkorkst und mit der
Verstaatlichung ist sie auch rechtlich
in Frage gestellt aber jedenfalls
politisch nicht haltbar
und das ist ja Herr Minister schon
bemerkenswert sie haben heute öffentlich
in dem Ausschuss erklärt das flüssiges
verfassungsfinanzverfassungsrechtlich
geprüft werden diese Prüfung würde noch
andauernd da würden sich es genau diese
Fragen stellen ja das ist so wenn ein
Unternehmen Staatsunternehmen wird dann
kann nicht eine
umlagebestand haben die eine Verteilung
zwischen Privatunternehmen vorgesehen
hat es gibt kein steuererfindungsrecht
für Staatsunternehmen da gilt das
Grundgesetz da wird unsere Verfassung
und ist ja schon nun bemerkenswert dass
diese Frage zwar berechtigt ist in der
Bundesregierung aber der federführende
Finanzminister sagt diese Frage ist
geklärt die gasumlage geht und sie als
der Erfinder der Umlage sagt nein nein
es muss noch geklärt werden ich sage
Ihnen Sie werden es ja morgen unseren
Antrag ablehnen das sind aber ihre
absatzbewegungen der gasumlage die
Geister die sie riefen die wollen sie
loswerden weil sie merken dass es
funktioniert sie sprechen jetzt von
einer Brücke es war doch bisher auch
schon zeitlich befristet eine Brücke wo
er hinten bis die Verstaatlichung
umgesetzt ist nach ihrer Auffassung in
drei Monaten oder so es zeigt die
gasumlage ist der große Elefant im Baum
der Ampel sie wissen sie ist vor die
Wand gefahren aber keiner spricht es
heute offen aus
und es galt von Anfang an sie halten
sich mit dem Beschluss für diese
gasumlage nicht an ihr eigenes Gesetz in
ihrem eigenen Gesetz haben sie eine
Priorisierung vorgesehen sie haben
gesagt da muss erst einmal geprüft
werden ob man Unternehmen stützen kann
und nur wenn es durch eine Stützung
alleine nicht ausreicht dann gibt es
eine zweite Stufe die könnte die
gasumlage sein sie haben noch bis zum
heutigen Tage bis zum heutigen Tage auch
heute nicht nie überzeugen transparent
dargelegt warum eine Stützung
notleidende Unternehmen nicht
ausreichend wäre um in dieser
Krisensituation Schieflagen abzuwenden
den Gasmarkt am Funktionieren zu halten
bis heute nicht transparent vorgelegt
stattdessen den zweiten Schritt gemacht
und den verkorkst so geht es nicht und
deshalb muss es aufgehoben werden
und in ihrem eigenen Gesetz schreiben
sie aber das muss alles ganz transparent
dargestellt werden ja ist unsere Meinung
als Opposition wir wollen das ist
transparent dargelegt wird bis zum
heutigen Tag weist aber kein Mensch wie
diese gasumlage berechnet ist Herr
Minister Herbig sie machen daraus ein
Staatsgeheimnis sagen Sie uns wie sie
berechnet wurde und sagen Sie uns warum
Sie denn genauso hoch bleiben soll nach
Ihren Vorstellungen wenn Sie die die sie
Trittbrettfahrer nennen die gasumlage
die gasumlage bekommen sollen Herr
Kollege obwohl sie satte Gewinne machen
obwohl Aktionäre Dividenden bekommen
obwohl Mitarbeiter Prämien erhalten die
sollen die gasumlage bekommen und das
ist nicht in Ordnung und wenn sie die
jetzt rausschmeißen sie haben noch gar
keinen Vorschlag dafür vorgelegt aber
wenn Sie die rauswerfen dann muss doch
auch die Höhe sich ändern legen Sie es
transparent da ist nicht passiert
und was wir uns fragen sie haben den
ganzen Sommer unter dem Eindruck unserer
Kritik immer wieder angekündigt ja wir
müssen nachbessern wir haben vergessen
bei den festverträgen des im Gesetz zu
regeln wir haben es vergessen bei der
Fernwärme wir haben das mit den
Trittbrettfahrern nicht gesehen das muss
alles nachgebessert werden wir werden
eine eine Revision des
energiesicherungsgesetzes vorlegen und
da ist dann alles drin da wird alles
nachgebessert jetzt ist dieses Gesetz da
es ist diese Woche im Bundestag wir
haben reingeschaut nichts davon ist drin
nichts davon ist drin wie lange
angekündigten Nachbesserung sind nicht
in ihrem Gesetz und auch das ist
eigentlich diese gasumlage wird nie
kommen weil so wie sie es aufgeklärt
haben funktioniert es nicht und deshalb
stimmen sie morgen unserem Antrag zu
folgen Sie unseren Argumenten wir haben
den besseren Weg
[Applaus]
tatsächlich hier im Bundestag der Antrag
der Unionsfraktion auf der Tagesordnung
die gasumlage nicht einzuführen wie sie
von der Bundesregierung geplant ist zum
ersten Oktober sondern für die Rettung
von Gasversorgern wie uniper den
Stadthaushalt zuzuziehen und heute
morgen hatte Robert Habegger öffentlich
verkündet dass die gasumlage ab Oktober
trotzdem das uniper verstaatlicht wird
erstmal greifen soll
und das ist im Moment die Gemengelage
jetzt hören wir Bernd Westphal für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
wir befinden uns in einer sehr
schwierigen wirtschaftlichen Situation
ich glaube die Dimension ist so dass wir
seit 1945 so eine Situation noch nie
hatten
und wir haben aus der Fragestunde heraus
diese aktuelle Stunde nun aber der
Vorredner von der Union hat diese Frage
die da steht Gas und öleporte überhaupt
nicht erwähnt in seiner Antwort hier
sondern hat sich konzentriert auf die
Frage ob wir die gasumlage nun bekommen
oder nicht ich will Ihnen mal sagen
diese Bundesregierung ist in einem
Krisenmanagement wo alle Ministerinnen
und Minister verdienen Unterstützung zu
bekommen das ist eine der schwierigsten
Situationen die wir bisher hatten in
unserem Land und deshalb deshalb
kann man natürlich solche aktuellen
Stunden hier aufsetzen sie sind aber
nicht im Kern geeignet die großen
Probleme die wir haben zu lösen und
deshalb will ich Ihnen sagen dass diese
Regierung handlungsfähig ist
wenn wir dem gefolgt sind was sie
gefordert haben Herr Merz dass wir schon
im Frühjahr ein Gas Embargo gegen
Russland verhängt hätten hätten wir die
Situation schon viel verschärfter gehabt
vorm halben Jahr und deshalb war es
richtig daran festzuhalten zu sagen wir
müssen die Versorgungssicherheit ja Herr
März da waren sie leider nicht den Film
wir müssen die Versorgungssicherheit
garantieren und jetzt jetzt merken wir
dass wir eine Verschärfung haben wo das
was in Gang gebracht worden ist genau
die richtigen Antworten war nämlich eine
gasförderstruktur aufzubauen die die
Pipeline und die led-terminals an den
Häfen ermöglicht und diese Investition
diese Genehmigung sind relativ schnell
in diesem Parlament beschlossen worden
die Umsetzung Genehmigung erfolgt und
deshalb haben wir jetzt eine Alternative
zu dem Pipeline Geist aus Russland und
wir haben natürlich mit unseren
europäischen Freundinnen und Freunden
die Möglichkeiten genutzt dass auch die
Importe aus anderen Ländern aus
Frankreich aus Benelux aber auch aus
Norwegen verstärkt haben und deshalb ist
zum Beispiel so eine Maßnahme indem man
die
gasfüllstände in den gasspeichern
untertägig in Norddeutschland auch
gesetzlich flankiert hat und deshalb
können wir jetzt aus einer
gasspeichellage wo fast 90 Prozent der
Kapazitäten gefüllt sind in diesen
Winter gehen und das ist etwas was diese
Regierung oft entwickelt
wir unterstützen die Unternehmen die
energieintensiven Unternehmen und diese
Programme werden erweitert das ist
angekündigt worden weil natürlich jeder
in seinem Gesprächen werkt vor Ort dass
wir mit einer Abhängigkeit in den
Unternehmen von Öl und Gas jetzt die
Situation haben dass mit diesen Preisen
keine Wettbewerbsfähigkeit mehr
dargestellt werden kann und deshalb wird
das flankiert unternehmen können
Leistungen beantragen die werden
erweitert das Ministerium ist dabei
dabei die Infrastruktur der Beantragung
zu erweitern und deshalb werden wir auch
hier Absicherungen treffen dass unsere
ökonomische Basis die wir haben nicht
gefährdet wird und ich will ihnen sagen
aus der Erfahrung der letzten Jahre wo
wir zusammen in der Regierung waren und
zu corona-pandemiezeiten ja auch
Hilfsprogramme auf den Weg gebracht
worden
das ist doch nicht zu Beginn der
Pandemie alle Unterstützungsprogramme
bis zuletzt durchdekliniert worden
sondern wir haben immer die Situation
gehabt wo wir anpassen mussten wo wir
neu justieren mussten corona-hilfe 1 2
und 3 sie wissen das doch aus ihrer
Erfahrung selber und deshalb ist das was
die Regierung macht angepasst an der
aktuellen Situation nachzusteuern genau
die richtige Politik
was unser Land stark macht und
auszeichnet als vierte größte
Wirtschaftsnation der Welt ist dass wir
eine gute Politik haben eine stabile
Regierung dass wir eine Industrie und
und innovativen Mittelstand haben ja gut
sie werden ja gleich noch genug Redezeit
haben um zu überlegen wie ihre Konzepte
sind das habe ich eben nur fokussiert
auf eine gasumlage gehört die im Grunde
gar nichts dazu mit zu tun hat was wir
da alles regeln müssen im Moment also
von von daher macht unser Land das stark
dass wir
innovative Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer haben die in einer
Transformation sind die für Sicherheit
sorgen mit Investitionen in Zukunft
Technologien genau um die Abhängigkeit
von fossilen Energien zu reduzieren das
ist der Weg in die Zukunft und nicht
Laufzeitverlängerung wie Sie es wollen
vielen Dank
für die SPD-Fraktion deren
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher ja auch
aus der SPD-Fraktion gab es heute
durchaus schon kritische Stimmen zum
Thema gasumlage beispielsweise von der
parlamentarischen Geschäftsführerin
Katja Mast die durchaus gesagt hat es
gäbe aus ihrer Sicht erhebliche
rechtliche Fragen und auch politische
was die Gasanlage Handlung erst Recht
vor dem Hintergrund der Verstaatlichung
des Energiekonzerns uniper Rainer Kraft
jetzt für die AFD
den Antrag von uns debattieren indem die
gasumlage neu geregelt werden soll denn
auch wir haben erkannt dass die
gasumlage so wie sie vom Ministerium
geplant worden ist so nicht kommen kann
wir freuen uns dass Sie das genauso
sehen vielen Dank dafür
kommen wir zu einem Thema was auf die
Frage Nummer 5 vom Kollegen gepper
zurück in dem ich zur Frage wann und wo
Gas und Öl wieder gestoppt werden soll
mit den Lieferungen erste vorbemerkung
das Energien war keine gute Idee und das
merkt man auch daran dass die arroganten
hochnäsigen reden der EU-Kommission und
anderer mittlerweile verstummt sind wir
sehen in wieburg oben das Ostern das Gas
lieber verbrennt zur Zeit also sonst zu
liefern
okay sie brauchen es trotzdem bringen
sie mich aus dem konzeptieren und
im Bahn Staatssekretär gesagt haben sie
haben jetzt die pizsäcker Schwedt und
der Treuhand gestellt das ist natürlich
eine Sache die kommen Muster der in der
Betreiber pinzinger Schwedt hat kein
Interesse daran Alternative lieferroten
die nicht über die drohballpalmler
Laufen zu machen ist verständlich sind
russische Konzern erhält zum russischen
Staat insofern war es klar dass diese
Konflikt kommen musste aber die Lösungen
die angedacht sind von ihnen und vor
allem auch von ihrem Staatssekretär und
der im ausschlus präsentiert worden sind
sind absolut ungenügend sie haben jetzt
mit der Begründung die nächsten drei
Monate gesichert von der Raffinerie weil
andere Sublieferanten und Partner nicht
mehr mit dieser Affäre leben wollen sie
haben nach wie vor kein Konzept wie es
ab dem 1 Januar in Schweden weitergehen
soll die Pipeline aus Rostock ist
ungenügend um die Produktion in Schwedt
aufrecht zu halten der Neubau der
Ertüchtigung einer neuen Pipeline dauert
gemäß ihrem Staatssekretär im Ausschuss
heute gesagt mindestens zwei Jahre das
heißt wir reden hier von Anfang 25 bis
dort wieder Ertüchtigung stattfinden
könnte
dass sie dem PCG der original russische
Betreiber nicht sagen wie ihre Pläne
ausgesehen haben ist ja soweit okay habe
ich ja erwartet dass sie jetzt wo sie es
in der treuen gestellt haben die
Schublade aufmachen und ihren
Versorgungsplan rausholen die versorgen
wie sie 100%, oder eine ausreichende
Auslastung der raffinerie-pca Schwedt
sicherstellen können über die Schiene
über das Wasser oder die Fluss hinauf
oder mit Lastwagen aber nichts davon ist
bloß angekommen nur die Ankündigung dass
in zwei Jahren eine Pipeline bauen
würden das heißt am 1.1 werden
offensichtlich in schwedte Lichter
ausgehen und dann kommen die anderen
Dinge die ihnen vorgestellt haben
nämlich die Ertüchtigung zu anderen
Standorten die mit Raffinerie nichts zu
tun haben wie Wasserstofferzeugung ein
kompletter Bruch einer Produktionskette
an einem traditionellen Standort der mit
den traditionellen Produktionen dort
nichts zu tun hat und wo viele Leute
nicht sicher sein können dass Ihre
berufliche Ausbildung danach noch
gebraucht wird das ist auch wieder nur
einmal ein Beispiel von Ihnen dass Sie
viel Geld in die Hand nehmen und Problem
die selbst verursacht haben auf
Steuerzahlerkosten zu lösen
zur Energie im allgemeinen ja die
Gaspreise sind voll der Herr Westphal
war voll des Lobes wieder von 90 Prozent
ja aber 90 Prozent von was die
gassprecher haben nämlich ungefähr 30
Prozent der Jahreskapazität also 90
Prozent von 30 Prozent sind 27 Prozent
die jahreskapitel befinden sich gerade
mit Milliarden in den Speichern 27
Prozent vom Jahr sind ungefähr
dreieinhalb Monate das muss aber
wirklich ein kurzer Winter sein und da
sind wir beim Ankündigungen unseres
Wirtschaftsministers wir hoffen auf
einen milden winterlimit wenn eine
Chance haben hier durchzukommen
was impliziert natürlich dass wenn wir
keine milder haben dass wir keine Chance
haben werden hier durchzukommen das ist
Energiepolitik auf dem Niveau eines
Schwellen und Entwicklungslandes oder
eines Industrie Landes unwürdig
zweitens die LNG Terminals wir haben zur
Hochzeit und ja es war zu viel und die
Abhängigkeit war schlecht 55 Milliarden
9 Kubikmeter Gas durch die Pipeline aus
Russland bekommen jetzt haben wir LNG
Terminals eine Kapazität eines
lng-terminals pro Jahr sind 5 Milliarden
Norm Kubikmeter nach einem risik braucht
man also 11 LNG Terminals und Riga
seffizierungseinheiten um die Kapazität
russischen pipeline-basis zu
kompensieren wir haben drei mit dessen
Hamburg gebaut wird und nicht pleite
geht dann haben wir drei das heißt die
Kapazität ist schon nicht ausreichend
und dann kommen wir zu der
entscheidenden Frage selbst wenn sie die
lngittermess gebaut haben und selbst
wenn Sie sie anschließend als deutsche
gasystem dann ist die Frage wie viel
Kontrakt des unterschrieben wie viel
energies wird irgendwo auf der Welt in
Tanker gepackt über die Meere gefahren
damit es in deutschen energy Terminals
angelandet werden kann um ins Deutsche
Gasnetz eingegasst zu werden durch Regen
davon hört man nichts an lng-table
allein bringt keinen einzigen Kubikmeter
kommen wir zu
den anderen Dingen die wir brauchen Herr
habe gesehen im Ministerium haben viel
Zeit verschwendet am 24 Februar war klar
dass wir ein Konflikt mit unserem großen
energielieferat in Russland kommen sie
haben bis zum Juni Juli gebraucht bis
sie es erlaubt haben dass wir weitere
Kohlekraftwerke anheizen um Strom zu
machen der Gas ersetzt sie weigert sich
nach wie vor Kernkraftwerke weiter zu
laufen zu lassen sie wollen
offensichtlich auch ab 1 weiterhin Gas
verbrennen und weiterhin Gas verstromen
weil nur ja die grüne Befindlichkeit
nicht gestört werden darf dass sie
weiterhin Kernkraftwerke betreiben das
heißt zu wenig zu spät und immer
Rücksicht nehmen auf die grüne Seele
weil er wieder Wahl in Niedersachsen
anstehen aber wir werden sehen was nach
der Valen Niedersachsen von ihren ganzen
Ankündigungen noch übrig bleiben wird
vielen Dank
ja in dieser aktuellen Stunde erwarten
wir jetzt am Rednerpult hier
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck der
aus dem Haushaltsausschuss hier
gegenüber geeignet ist ins Plenum zu
dieser
kurzfristig angeräumten Aktuellen Stunde
zur Gasanlage
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe und jungs-
ich rede total gerne hier und ich komme
auch jederzeit ich kann mich nur nicht
klonen ich war gerade im
Haushaltsausschuss auf Bitten der Union
und habe erzählt was es mit den Details
der unüberrettung oder für staatlichung
auf sich hat und ihre Kollegen waren
konsterniert dass ich abgerufen wurde
ich glaube sie müssen da ein paar Sachen
untereinander klären es gibt ja Telefon
aber
das ist nicht das ist nicht mein
Hauptpunkt mein Hauptpunkt ist ich
zitiere mit Verlaub der Präsidentin aus
der Frage die zu dieser aktuellen Stunde
geführt hat ich zitiere unter fünf den
Abgeordneten Gepard die Frage lautet
wann legt die Bundesregierung ein
konkreten ausstiegsfahrplan für
russische Öl-
ist Ihnen aufgefallen
dass Russland kein Gas mehr liefert dass
die politische Situation also nicht ist
dass wir uns einen Babo ausgedacht haben
sondern das Putin den Gashand abgedreht
hat sie sollten zumindest überlegen was
die Wirklichkeit an Aufgaben stellt wenn
sie schon nicht in bereit sind die
Antworten auf die Wirklichkeit zu
akzeptieren
Verantwortung dieser Fragen und ich gehe
gleich auf die gasumlage und die damit
verbundenen Debatten ein ein Wort zu
Schwedt es gab vom rechten Rand unter
anderem die Forderung kein Imago für
Schwedt
was sehen wir was im Moment passiert es
gibt ja keinen barco es kann russisches
Öl aus der Brust Pipeline raffiniert
werden in Schwedt aber niemand oder
immer weniger wollen es haben es gibt
Versicherungen es gibt Versicherungen
die nicht mehr versichern es gibt
Geldgeber die kein Geld mehr geben es
gibt Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
die sich zurückziehen es gibt Abnehmer
die nicht mehr abnehmen wollen das nicht
wegen meiner Politik sondern wegen das
wegen wegen Öl von Putin das im
europäischen Markt nicht mehr gefragt
ist das Zögern und das nicht agiert hat
Schweden diese Situation geführt und das
ist im übrigen auch die Begründung warum
wir eine Treuhand eingesetzt haben denn
die Begründung zur Einsetzung einer
Treuhand kann ja nur sein dass wir die
Energieversorgung im staatlichen Auftrag
sicherstellen weil sie sonst nicht
anders sicherzustellen wäre weil der
Markt ganz kollabiert wäre wegen der
oberkompliance in Schwedt
dann lassen Sie mich zur Gasanlage
kommen
und auf die Fragen des persönlich sehr
geschätzten Kollegen jung eingehen die
sogenannten trittbettfahrer also die
Unternehmen die von der Gasanlage
profitieren obwohl sie Gewinde machen
machen einen Anteil der gasumlage von
ungefähr acht Prozent aus das ist nicht
nichts aber es ist nicht so dass die
Berechnung die ja auf eine
preisprojektion abgezielt hat jetzt
sofort korrigiert werden müssen die
Systematik der gasumlage wie mehrfach im
Ausschuss erläutert ist dass die
quartalsweise justiert wird mit Blick
auf die Preise das kann auch vorgenommen
werden im Januar das ist aber auch die
Antwort warum diese acht Prozent jetzt
nicht den großen Unterschied machen
zweite Antwort wie wird die Gasanlage
berechnet auch das mehrfach dargestellt
die Unternehmen die berechtigt sind
stellen Anträge THG prüft diese Anträge
auf Plausibilität und daraus errechnet
sich dann gestreckt über den Zeitraum
des fand die gasumlage erhoben werden
kann Ende Ende Winter 24 die Summe die
dann im Welt erhoben werden soll sie
kann also nach oben wie nach unten
korrigiert werden so auch vorgesehen und
die
die Systematik und die Logik ist denkbar
klar und auch mehrfach erläutert dritter
Punkt dritter Punkt die rechtliche
Bewertung wenn ein Unternehmen in
staatlicher Hand Gerät wie jetzt Juniper
bzw es ist ja noch nicht in staatliche
Hand das wird ja noch ein paar Wochen
wahrscheinlich zwei bis drei Monate
dauern ist berechtigt und muss streng
erfolgen und dass ich diese Frage stellt
dass eine verfassungsrechtliche Normen
Prüfung erfolgen muss ist richtig und
ist notwendig ist System ein Unterschied
ob ein staatliches Unternehmen eine
Umlage bekommt oder einen mehrheitlich
privat gehaltenes Unternehmen das
Verfahren ist die Ressort mit Zeichnung
zur der Umlage denn wir haben heute
morgen oder heute die ressortbezeichnung
zu diesen genannten Punkten in das
Kabinett gebracht und im Rahmen dieser
Ressort Mitzeichnung wird diese Klärung
dann erfolgen und dann entsprechend
geklärt werden darüber lassen Sie mich
ganz kurz einmal darauf eingehen dass
ihre Forderung ist und vielleicht darf
ich den weiteren Rahmen fassen
ich erinnere mich daran wie wir damals
war ich Parteivorsitzender während der
letzten zweieinhalb Jahre diskutiert
haben wie wir uns politisch Verhalten in
Zeiten einer nationalen Krise Corona und
wir waren damals in der Opposition und
hat viel uns hat vieles nicht im Detail
gepasst was sie verantwortet haben auch
die jetzigen Koalitionspartner wir haben
gesehen dass soloselbständige nicht
genug bedacht worden wir haben gesehen
dass nicht schnell genug Vorsorge
geschaffen wurde wir haben gesehen dass
Kinder und Alleinerziehende nicht
berücksichtigt worden und so weiter dass
die Förderprogramme nicht ausreichten
das haben wir immer wieder im Detail
kritisiert aber wir haben wenn es darauf
ankommt immer die Verantwortung gesucht
Wir haben ihre Politik obwohl wir
abgewichen sind in der Sache immer
wieder unterstützt jetzt haben wir eine
Situation Corona ist ja noch nicht
vorbei du sich dem Motiv den Krisen
Aufschaukeln drohen wo wir hohe
Inflation haben und gleichzeitig die
Drohung einer Rezession das muss man
sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
was dieses Land erlebt und was hören wir
von der Opposition und das ist der
eigentliche Punkt die Gasanlage muss weg
sind wir denn hier im Fußball
Stadion das eine Demo muss weg sie sind
die muss weg auf Position was ist denn
das für eine Antwort fragen Sie mich mal
dass wir alles nicht gefällt und das ist
mir wünschen würde was alles weg muss
aber das ist doch keine Politik was
kommt denn stattdessen was ist denn die
Antwort darauf und wenn Sie schon wenn
Sie sich schon entschieden haben nicht
konstruktive Opposition zu sein dann
sollten sie wenigstens die Traute haben
zu ihren eigenen Anträgen auch
Wahrheiten und Ausspruch zu geben und
das tun sie nämlich nicht natürlich gibt
es eine Möglichkeit anderes Geld
aufzunehmen dann müssen sich hier
herstellen und sagen statt der gasumlage
wollen wir jetzt sofort etwa 35
Milliarden Euro aufnehmen oder die
unternehmenskapitalisieren das tun sie
aber nicht sie stellen sich ja hin mit
Klumpen Forderungen dann seien sie
wenigstens ehrlich und diese Ehrlichkeit
die vermisse ich in dieser Debatte die
Ehrlichkeit und die
Verantwortungsbereitschaft sie haben
sich für einen Weg entschieden ich
glaube nicht dass es der richtige ist
von der Fragestellung die falsch ist die
quasi wenn ich das sagen unterstellt als
würde die Bundesregierung ein Gas
embargo verhängen wo wir uns bewusst
dagegen ausgesprochen haben von einer
falschen eine falsche Möglichkeit in
siguierende Fragenstellung bis zur
Verweigerung einer Antwort stellen sie
sich ja hin holen die Abgeordneten aus
dem kämmern hervor um keine Antwort zu
geben so stelle ich mir Opposition nicht
vor danke schön
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister hier in
der Aktuelle Stunde die die
cdu/csu-fraktion ja kurzzeitig verlangt
hatte und das Robert Habeck hier im
Plenum tatsächlich doch etwas lauter
wird und auch doch sehr vehement an die
Verantwortung gerade der
cdu/csu-fraktion
appelliert das hört man sonst auch nicht
so häufig also die gasumlage sie ist
strittig das wird sich durch diese
Plenarwoche ziehen aber hören wir
erstmal weiter in die Debatte rein jetzt
für die Linke Alexander
ulrichsgeschichte
aber die Union macht sich schon
lächerlich
Stunde
[Applaus]
beantragt hatte wo man das Thema
unterbringen konnte und morgen auch noch
den Antrag zur gaspreisumlage hier im
Bundestag hat also lächerlicher kann man
sich nicht machen also ohne Quatsch das
war jetzt keine große Stunde dieser
Oppositionsfraktion und ganz nebenbei
ist ihnen und wieder mal klar geworden
dass wir mit vielen Problemen schon
weiter wären wenn jetzt 16 Jahre lang
gerade von ihrer Fraktion ihrer
Regierung der Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien nicht blockiert worden wäre sie
kämpfen heute noch um jedes Windrad sie
kämpfen heute um die Verlängerung der
Kernkraftwerke und machen sich hier in
breiten Fuß also besser hätten sie heute
nichts gesagt
aber Herr Minister Habeck sie machen es
natürlich auch der
Opposition ein Stück weit leicht ich
zitiere ich zitiere sie sie haben diese
Woche irgendwo gesagt wenn beim Gas
sparen alles gut geht und wir Glück mit
dem Wetter haben dann haben wir eine
Chance gut durch den Winter zu kommen
kann sein dass das ehrlich war aber
deutschland braucht kein Minister der
glaubt und hofft und nach Glück sucht
sondern wir brauchen ein Minister der
Macht und das ist das entscheidende
Deutschland brauchen diesen Tagen ein
Minister der Macht und Herr Habig da
haben sie zurzeit wenig geliefert wir
haben heute morgen gerade im
Wirtschaftsausschuss des Bundestags
darüber geredet was passiert denn mit
den unternehmenshilfen ich glaube
dreieinhalbtausend anträge sind bis
jetzt gestellt worden noch keine 40 sind
zur Auszahlung gekommen jeden Tag den
wir hier verschenken gehen Betriebe in
insolvent ob sie das verstehen oder
nicht jeden Tag wo wir hier verschenken
gehen 100.000 Arbeitsplätze in die
Gefährdung viele Unternehmen wissen
nicht wie sie über den Winter überstehen
die wissen nicht wie es im nächsten
Monat produzieren wollen und von dieser
Bundesregierung wird Woche für Woche
dieses Thema verschlafen wir brauchen
ganz dringend endlich und schnelle und
unbürokratische unternehmenshilfen um
die nächsten Wochen und Monaten zu
bestehen
und der Habeck
[Applaus]
sie haben es gesagt die Union macht sie
es einfach und sagt gaspreisumlage Weg
wir haben noch das linke seit der ersten
Stunde gesagt wir sagen wir können in
einer Situation wo die Energiepreise so
durch die Decke gehen können wir nicht
weiter die Verbraucher und die
Unternehmen mit in dieser Umlage
versehen das haben wir von Anfang an
gesagt dieser Graf
gaspreiszuschlag muss weg da haben sie
eben die Union ja kritisiert dann
sollten sie sagen wo die 35 Milliarden
herkommen ich sage ihnen dass man ganz
ehrlich während dieser Krise nicht
versteht dass sie ähnlich oder größer
ist wie Corona und immer noch an der
Schuldenbremse festhält hat nicht
verstanden was jetzt getan werden muss
die Schuldenbremse muss weg die muss
ausgesetzt werden ein weiteres Jahr dann
hätten wir die 35 Milliarden auf andere
Art und Weise und Verbraucher und die
KMU zu unterstützen das wäre die
richtige Antwort und Sie müssen ob sie
wollen oder nicht sie müssen mit der FDP
jetzt langsam mal in der Bundesregierung
Tacheles reden denn eine eine FDP die
weiterhin die Schuldenbremse einhalten
will in einer Situation wie sie selbst
beschreiben hohe Inflation und
Rezessionsgefahren der muss der
versündigt sich an den kommenden
Generationen denn jedes Unternehmen das
in Deutschland abwandert jedes
Unternehmen das Pleite macht jedes
Unternehmen das sich jetzt fragt warum
ist in Amerika der graph-preis zehnmal
geringer wie bei uns diese Unternehmen
wenn es weg sind sind sie nicht mehr da
und die kommen Generationen werden diese
Arbeitsplätze leider suchen deshalb die
FDP versündigt sich mit ihrer
Schuldenbremse an der Zukunft diesen
Landes
und Herr Habig wir müssen jetzt auch
langsam tatsächlich sie haben nicht mehr
lange Zeit sie haben nicht mehr lange
Zeit sie müssen jetzt langsam liefern
und die unternehmenshilfen können nicht
mehr lange auf sich warten wir haben
auch Ihnen heute morgen ja die Frage
auch im Wirtschaftsausschuss gestellt wo
kommen die Milliarden her sie haben sie
nicht so richtig beantwortet sie haben
gesagt ja gut entweder müssen wir die
Einnahmen erhöhen oder die Ausgaben
irgendwo anders so einschränken ja wo
wollen Sie denn sparen um die
zusätzlichen unternehmensilben zu
bezahlen ich sage noch einmal die
aktuelle Haushaltsplanung für
2023 wird nicht halten sie wird in
Herausforderungen nicht gerecht und da
muss diese Bundesregierung endlich
liefern und ganz nebenbei
der Bundeskanzler hat im Februar bereits
gesagt die
Sanktionen dürfen uns nicht härter
treffen wie den Putin oder Russland
selbst und ich glaube das gehört auch zu
Ehrlichkeit dazu dass wir jetzt auch
jeden Tag spüren dass diese Sanktionen
uns schon härter treffen als Protein und
deshalb muss man auch die
Sanktionspolitik hinterfragen denn es
ist doch wirklich so dass
Gazprom weiterhin Super Geschäfte macht
während wir nicht mehr wissen oder die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger draußen diese
ihre Gasrechnungen bezahlen sollen das
heißt wir dürfen nicht nur darüber
nachdenken mit entlastungspakete wie wir
die am Schluss wieder die Pflaster
draufsetzen sondern wir müssen auch die
Sanktionspolitik hinterfragen denn die
schadet uns mehr als Russland vielen
Dank ja auch die Linke hat heute morgen
Fragen gestellt an Robert Habeck bzw
auch im Laufe des Tages der
Wirtschaftsminister in diversen
bundestagsausschüssen zu verschiedenen
Themen interessant wird es jetzt was die
FDP von ihrem Koalitionspartner
sozusagen wissen möchte denn was die
gasumlage anbelangt da hat der
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
gesagt die gasumlage die müssen nicht
mehr auf den Prüfstand also im Gegensatz
zu Robert Habeck hören wir Lukas Köhler
für die FDP sich mal hier hinstellen
würde und amerikanisches fracking-gas
gut finden würde das wundert mich schon
sehr also da muss ich sagen dass sie
hier Verteidigungen für Amerika
Vorbringen ich hätte andere Politik von
ihnen erwartet zumindest gedacht dass
sie das anders formulieren aber machen
Sie ruhig aber ein Punkt haben sie ihr
richtigerweise ausgeführt wir haben eine
reale Knappheit am Gasmarkt der Gaspreis
in Deutschland ist so hoch weil er real
knapp ist und das ist eine
Herausforderung das ist aber keine
Herausforderung weil wir zu wenig
fördern das Problem ist ja wollen wir
auch aber das Problem ist
das Putin einen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine führt und das aufgrund dieses
Krieges
Gas knapp ist meine Damen und Herren wir
reden ja nicht im luftleeren Raum
sondern natürlich ist es an der
aktuellen Situation Putin Schuld darüber
und brechen aber
reale Probleme heißen wir brauchen auch
reale Lösungen und Liebe Union ein
bisschen mehr marktwirtschaftliches
Verständnis von ihnen hätte ich schon
erwartet was sie hier vortragen dass sie
sich hier hinstellen und sagen naja bei
den realen Problemen was einzige was uns
einfällt ist heute Markus Söder der die
Schuldenbremse in Frage stellt seien sie
was hineinfällt keine
marktwirtschaftliche Lösung keinen
Ansatz keine Alternative dazu wie Sie
die gasumlage denn anders gestalten
wollen wird das hätte ich von Ihnen Herr
Jung bei ihrer Verantwortung die sie
hier mittragen hätte ich von Ihnen
erwartet dass sie hier sich hinstellen
und sagen das ist eine bessere
Alternative nichts kommt dazu nichts und
jetzt sagen Sie naja uniper wird
gerettet es wird zu einem
Staatsunternehmen für kurze Zeit es geht
natürlich wieder zurück in den Markt es
wird sogar übertragen wenn man mal sich
überlegt das kommt von dem schwedischen
Staatsunternehmen geht über Deutschland
und wird dann
marktwirtschaftsunternehmen da freue ich
mich drauf wir mehr Markt schaffen mehr
privatisierungs eigentlich gut aber
meine Damen und Herren dass wir in
dieser Situation
du dadurch dass wir uniper jetzt retten
um den Gasmarkt stabil zu halten weil
eine weitere disruption des Gasmarktes
würde ja nicht dazu führen dass
irgendetwas besser wird sondern wenn
jetzt unüber pleite gehen würde würde
das einen ripple-effekt ein
kaskadeneffekt im Markt haben und das
würde zu noch mehr Probleme führen
deswegen ist es richtig das Robert
Habeck sich hinstellt dass die ganze
Bundesregierung sich hinstellt und sagt
wir retten dieses Unternehmen in einer
schweren Krise
aber es genauso richtig dass die Preise
ja weiterhin bestehen bleiben und falls
Sie das Prinzip der gasumlage noch nicht
so ganz durchdrungen haben das Problem
ist doch das Gasanbieter aktuell
Langfristverträge haben zu ganz anderen
Preisen als die am Spotmarkt im Moment
vorherrschen und weit ist also am Markt
wird anders gehandelt als das was sie
langfristvertreten haben und diese
Langfristverträge sorgen noch dafür dass
Deutschland im Moment stabil ist und
wenn jetzt auf einmal Russland kein Gas
mehr liefert naja was müssen die dann
machen dann müssen sie an genau diesem
Markt einkaufen meine Damen und Herren
ist es völlig richtig das werden
Instrument finden dass da zu hilft wenn
das nicht die gasumlage ist können wir
gerne über andere Instrumente sprechen
aber das wir jetzt auf einmal 38
Milliarden aus dem Bundeshaushalt
einfach mal so aufnehmen
und es werden stündlich mehr sagen wir
selber ja wenn wir einfach mal so die
Schuldenbremse in einer Inflationszeit
abschaffen das ist Wahnsinn und das dass
ihre ökonomische Intelligenz völlig in
zu überfordern scheint das ist ein
wirkliches Problem ich glaube meine
Damen und Herren und ich glaube das
müssen wir schnell tun wir brauchen eine
gemeinsame Konsens darüber wie wir mit
den Märkten wie wir mit dem Energiemarkt
umgehen wir müssen auch die Unternehmen
retten und den Unternehmen helfen und
das ist auch richtig dass wir da schon
als Regierung viel getan haben müssen
auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
hinterlassen aber gaspreisdeckel
vorzuschlagen in americorder
einzugreifen von der sie die Effekte gar
nicht kennen meine Damen und Herren ich
erwarte mir mehr von der Union erwarte
mir sehr viel mehr von einer Partei die
für sich die soziale Marktwirtschaft
einfach und ich erwarte mir auch als
Oppositionsfraktion sehr viel mehr
konstruktive konstruktive Kritik mit
Vorschlägen
und deswegen ist es meiner Meinung nach
absolut absurd sich hier hinzustellen
und zu sagen ja wir Finanzierung lassen
wir offen wir stellen mal die
Schuldenbremse in Frage aber
wir weiten die Inflation aus aber das
Instrument mögen wir trotzdem nicht ja
meine Damen und Herren das ist doch
keine konstruktive Kritik das ist meiner
Meinung nach das eigenständnis nicht
genau zu wissen was man will und sich
nicht ganz so sicher zu sein wie der
Markt funktioniert ich glaube dass wir
genau an der richtigen Stelle darüber
diskutieren wie wir die gasumlage besser
machen können und ich glaube auch dass
wir genau an der richtigen Stelle
nämlich hier darüber diskutieren wie wir
dieses Land über diese wahrliche Krise
bringen aber nicht indem wir die
Inflation noch weiter anheizen und
weitere Schulden ausnehmen und die Gas
die Geldmenge weiterarbeiten sondern
dadurch dass wir vernünftige
angebotsorientierte Wirtschaftspolitik
machen auf dem Weg sind wir und dafür
danke ich der Regierung ganz herzlich
für die FDP-Fraktion es ist
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
und jetzt hören wir für die
cdu/cs-fraktionen hier am Rednerpult
ebenfalls stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender der CDU
CSU-Fraktion in dem Fall
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Frage wie wir unabhängig
werden von russischen Gaslieferungen ob
er ein Unternehmen ein Gasversorger wie
uniper mit Milliarden gestützt wird wie
die gasumlage weitergeht das beschäftigt
Millionen Menschen und das bewegt viele
Milliarden da stellen sich Fragen Fragen
die wir heute im Ausschuss gestellt
haben Fragen die wir in der Fragestunde
Herr Kollege Mors genau in diesem
Zusammenhang gestellt haben Fragen die
aber nicht beantwortet worden sind und
lieber Herr Minister Habeck anstatt die
Opposition zu beschimpfen hätten sie ihr
lieber gerade ein paar Antworten auf
diese Fragen geben können da kommen
nicht Abgeordnete aus den Kammern das
ist gelebte parlamentarische Demokratie
wenn Fragen wie diese hier diskutiert
werden
und
fragen fragen die die Wirklichkeit
stellt kann ich Ihnen sagen wir werden
ab dem 1 Oktober 2022 in Gaspreis
aufgrund gesetzlicher Vorgaben anheben
müssen das ist konkrete Wirklichkeit wo
sich Fragen stellen nämlich Briefe die
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger gerade
bekommen 20 Millionen Gaskunden die
gasumlage wird konkret nur leider ist
nichts geklärt nichts ist klar man kommt
ja kaum noch hinterher die antwerten
handwerklichen Fehler wer zahlt was
Mehrwertsteuer Ja oder Nein Unternehmen
mit Milliarden gewinnen die auch
profitieren sollen verteilen
Umverteilung von unten nach oben
Anpassungen an die Regelung werden vor
Wochen angekündigt heute werden welche
in die Ressortabstimmung gegeben während
der zuständige Minister gleichzeitig
finanzverfassungsrechtliche Zweifel hat
und die hält die FDP ist ja der letzte
Fan der Umlage die anderen Koalitionäre
stellen sie auch schon in Frage die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zahlen gerade ab
dem 1 oktober in zehn Tagen eine Umlage
bei der wir da klar ist wer wofür für
wen zahlt und ob sie überhaupt kommt und
das ist Afrika aus PUR in einer Zeit wo
es Sicherheit und kleinbarkeit bräuchte
und auch zur juniperettung die auf den
ersten Blick konsequent ist stellen sich
zumindest mal fragen die wir auch hier
stellen und wie viele Milliarden handelt
es sich denn bei welchen Instrumenten
für Juniper warum beteiligt sich der
finnische Staat als Miteigentümer nicht
stärker ist diese Bundesregierung nun
Eigentümer von Kernkraftwerken in
Schweden und Kohlekraftwerken in
Russland und wenn ja und wenn ja warum
betreiben sie in anderen Ländern dann
was sie im eigenen Land nicht ans Netz
kriegen und am Netz halten wollen denn
wenn wir Herr Minister
wenn wir die fragen uns anschauen die
Fragen die die Wirklichkeit stellt die
Frage die die Wirklichkeit stellt ist
nämlich die wo kommt der Strom wo kommt
die Energie her und in einer Zeit eines
angebotsschocks geht es darum jedes
Angebot jede Möglichkeit zu nutzen ich
kann Ihnen sagen welche Fragen die
Wirklichkeit stellt warum sind sieben
Monate nach Kriegsbeginn nur zwei
Kohlekraftwerke bisher zusätzlicher Netz
das ist eine Frage die die Wirklichkeit
stellt kann ich noch eine Frage stellen
die die Wirklichkeit stellt
warum sind sieben Monate nach
Kriegsbeginn nachdem wir das hier zu
Abstimmung gestellt haben sie es
abgelehnt haben sie im Sommer
angekündigt haben jetzt erst Vorschläge
vorliegen wie man es vielleicht mal
regelt sieben Monate später die
biogasmöglichkeiten die wir im Land
haben für mehr Erzeugung immer noch
nicht am Netz das ist die Frage die die
Wirklichkeit stellt
und ja die Frage die die Wirklichkeit
aufstellt ist die warum mitten im Winter
in einer Energiekrise wo die Strompreise
auf Rekordniveau sind und für die Frage
haben wir genug Energie im Land sich
stellt eine Frage die die Wirklichkeit
stellt ist warum lassen wir drei sichere
und verlässliche Kernkraftwerke nicht
weiterlaufen das sind die Fragen die
sich stellen und die Sie hier nicht
beantwortet haben diese hier nicht
beantwortet haben
und dann gibt es noch eine sehr
entscheidende Frage die die Wirklichkeit
stellt nämlich die was eigentlich in der
Regierung los ist das alles wäre ja in
normalen Zeiten ganz unterhaltsam was da
passiert
der Finanzminister und der
Wirtschaftsminister sind im täglichen
Streit miteinander
Schuldenbremse
weiterlaufen der Kernkräfte gasumlage Ja
oder Nein finanzverfassungsrechtliche
Zweifel Ja oder Nein in normalen Zeiten
wäre das vielleicht unterhaltsam wir
sind aber in einer der schwersten Krisen
unseres Landes viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger Millionen sind verunsichert die
Heiz Methode beginnt spätestens am 1
Oktober sie fragen sich was sie erwartet
welche Kosten auf Sie zukommen und das
gilt auch für viele Unternehmen im Land
und in einer Zeit wie dieser kriegen wir
nicht Führung Einigkeit ein beherztes
Handeln sondern täglichen Streit
zwischen Finanz und Wirtschaftsminister
sekundiert von FDP und Grünen und der
Anfeuerung der SPD was dieses Land
braucht und das ist die Frage der
Wirklichkeit die sich stellt ist eine
Regierung die das nötige tut die geeint
handelt die in Zeiten der Unsicherheit
nicht noch täglich zusätzliche
Verunsicherung schafft das ist die Frage
die die Wirklichkeit stellt
für die
cdu/csu-fraktion ja die gaseumlage ab 1
oktober soll sie kommen
2,4 Cent pro Kilowattstunde betragen und
das Ganze zu private und ja gewerbliche
Verbraucher
die gasumlage die müssen ja zunächst die
Energieversorger bezahlen und das könnte
dann in bei den November oder Dezember
Rechnung dann für die Endkunden sichtbar
werden was das an konkreter Belastung
heißen würde
jemand wie sie mit ihrer Leistungsbilanz
in der Regierung in der letzten großen
Krise dieses Landes den Mund hier so
voll nehmen kann das ist eine Frage die
sich die Wirklichkeit stellt
und eine weitere Frage die sich ja die
Wirklichkeit stellt und vermehrt manche
Aussagen altern ja schlecht im Laufe der
Zeit Anfang März am 10 märz haben sie
gefordert dass wir einen barco auf
russisches Gas aussprechen sollen das
war ihre Forderung aus Anfang März ihr
Kollege Kiesewetter hat im gleichen
Atemzug gefordert dann müsste doch das
Land einfach mal den gürtelenger
schneiden das ist die Frage die sich
heute die würzeigkeit stellen was wäre
denn passiert wenn wir ihnen gefolgt
wäre was wäre denn passiert mit den
gasspeichern in diesem Land was wäre
denn mit der industriellen Substanz in
diesem Land passiert zu einem Zeitpunkt
wo wir deutlich abhängiger waren von
russischen Gas als wir es heute sind
denn diese Bundesregierung mit dem
Bundeskanzler und dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister haben seit
Ende des letzten Jahres noch bevor noch
bevor der russische Angriffskrieg
erfolgt ist angefangen sich aber einen
Weg der Unabhängigkeit von russischer
Energie zu machen weil doch völlig klar
war dass das was Peter Altmaier zugel
hat dass ich nämlich die Gasspeicher
leeren dass wir hier in dieser
Abhängigkeit drin sind das hat ihr
Wirtschafts- und Energieminister
zugelassen während diese Bundesregierung
als eine der ersten Maßnahmen
eingeleitet für unabhängiger werden von
russischer Energie das ist doch die
Frage die sich die Wirklichkeit stellt
warum sie das zugelassen haben und diese
Bundesregierung seit dem ersten Tag
genau dagegen anarbeiten musste
und wir sehen doch dass Putin genau mit
dieser Vorbereitung die Gasspeicher
leerlaufen zu lassen von Anfang an noch
einen hybridenkrieg geführt hat ein
hybridenkrieg in dem Gas in dem Energie
eine Waffe gegen den Westen gegen die
Demokratie war und da ist doch genau das
gleiche was uns klar sein muss genauso
wie in der Ukraine gilt gilt auch in
dieser hybridenkriegsform Putin darf
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen und deswegen
ist auch unsere Verantwortung dass wir
das landstabilisieren dass wir den
Haushalten über preisdecke eine
Verlässlichkeit über den Winter anbieten
dass wir dazu kommen und das ist ja ein
bisschen absurd dass sie mit dieser
Frage über die gasumlage hier eigentlich
die viel breiter gefasste aktuelle
Stunde zu der Frage von Bezahlbarkeit
und industrieller Substanz ja hier
verdrängt haben das wäre doch eigentlich
die Frage gewesen über die wir hier in
aller breiteten diskutieren müssen wie
denn tatsächlich in Sicherheit dafür
organisiert wird dass die Menschen neben
der Frage Gas zu haben also
Versorgungssicherheit auch eine
Bezahlbarkeit sichergestellt werden kann
wie wir genau dazu kommen dass wir über
eine preisdeckung eine Preisbremse über
einen Grundtarif es schaffen dass eben
spar-anreize geschaffen aber
gleichzeitig Versorgungssicherheit und
Bezahlbarkeit garantiert werden können
wie wir es doch genau hinbekommen dass
wir und es wurde heute morgen in beiden
Ausschüssen sehr ausführlich diskutiert
wie wir es eben hinbekommen dass wir den
Unternehmen ein Unterstützungsprogramm
anbieten was eben nicht mehr von der
Definition bin ich auf einer kübelliste
bin ich Energie und handelsintensiv
ausgeht sondern bin ich betroffen das
ist doch die entscheidende Frage die
viele Unternehmen im Mittelstand im
Handwerk gerade umtreibt kann ich mich
darauf verlassen unterstützt zu werden
und da haben wir heute morgen eine klare
Antwort darauf gegeben ja die
Unternehmen können sich genau darauf
verlassen und diese Frage hier im Plenum
zu debattieren haben sie mit ihrem
lächerlichen polit-theater leider hier
verdrängt aber sie kriegen die Antworten
trotzdem
und
ich hätte mir in der Tat einfach von
ihnen wirklich mehr
konstruktiven Umgang und auf
staatspolitischer Verantwortung
gewünscht sowohl er mehr als auch
ersparen wie sie mit ihrem
Ministerpräsidenten der CSU in Bayern in
die Debatte einsteigt wie wir eigentlich
dieses Land entlasten ist doch ein
Absurdität nicht zu übertreffen da sage
ich mal ganz deutlich mit dem Blick auch
auf Niedersachsen mit Stefan weil der
gesagt hat er ist bereit eine Milliarde
Euro und die Hand zu nehmen als nach
Niedersachsen um eben die Unternehmen zu
stabilisieren um eben Nachfolge Lösung
für eine und eure Tickets zu finanzieren
um ein härtefallfond für die Stadtwerke
und die kommunalen Einrichtung zu
organisieren das ist doch
verantwortliche Politik in einer
Krisensituation und sich nicht
hinzustellen und zwar mit mir halt
keiner geredet ich bin nicht bereit dazu
das ist eine wirklich keine
staatspolitische Verantwortung und
ehrlicherweise hätte ich von ihnen mehr
erwartet vielleicht aber auch es ist
eine Frage die sich die Wirklichkeit
stellt man darf es von der Union in
diesen Tag eben nicht mehr erwarten
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
als Koalition wie als Bundesregierung
nehmen vom ersten Tag die Frage der
energiepolitischen Unabhängigkeit der
Versorgungssicherheit der Bezahlbarkeit
für dieses Land für die Menschen für die
Unternehmen Ernst das ist eine der
Kernaufgaben seit unserem Amtsantritt
diesen Aufgaben fühlen wir uns weiter
verpflichtet da werden wir uns von ihnen
nicht aus dem Konzept bringen lassen wir
arbeiten daran die Antworten liegen zum
Teil auf dem Tisch die anderen Antworten
arbeiten wir sauber aus dafür freue ich
mich wenn sie irgendwann mal auf ihren
konstruktiven Weg zurückkommen wir
werden dann weiterarbeiten vielen
herzlichen Dank
für die Sozialdemokraten und jetzt hören
wir in dieser aktuellen Stunde die
nächsten Redner ausziehen rein der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen das ist
der Abgeordnete Dieter janitschek ist
der wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Grünen Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin zum Anfang
dieser Debatte darf ich feststellen dass
die Union den heiligen Gral der
Schuldenbremse heute endgültig geopfert
hat das ist die
absolute Konsequenz ihrer politischen
Forderungen
industriestrompreis vier Cent haben wir
heute schon gehört die gas-umlage aus
Steuermitteln ich kann mich auch noch
als Anträgen von ihnen erinnern wo sie
die Energiesteuer in auf ein Mindestmaß
senken wollen ich will das gar nicht
alles zusammenbrechen da ist die
Linkspartei solide als sie in den
Forderungen aber ich will auch ein Lob
damit verbinden ich halte es nämlich für
verantwortungsvoll in dieser Krise zu
sagen wir müssen jetzt den finanziellen
Spielraum des Staates erweitern um
Unternehmen und betroffenen Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern zu helfen das müssen wir
jetzt darf man sie aber auch nicht aus
der Verantwortung nehmen was sie in der
Vergangenheit geleistet haben schauen
Sie mal ich schaue gar nicht auf 16
Jahre vielleicht sogar auf ein Zeitraum
den sie in dem Recherche Magazin
Korrektiv org nachlesen können die
Verflechtungen von Unionspolitikern auch
Markus Söder mit den großen
russischhörigen gasimporteuren mit
dieser Politik die Sie zu verantworten
haben uns in diese Krise hineingetrieben
zu haben diese große Abhängigkeit von
russischen Gas ist auch eine
Abhängigkeit die die Union erzeugt hat
und das verbunden mit einem historischen
Versagen beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien über Jahrzehnten hätten wir
heute schon einen großen Ausbau auf den
Weg gebracht hätten wir
energieeinspeicherung hätten wir
Speichermöglichkeiten geschaffen hätten
wir diese Krisensituation heute nicht
auch das müssen sie zur Kenntnis nehmen
und wir werden sie aus dieser
Verantwortung nicht entlassen
gleichzeitig
gibt es kein Ministerium
seit ich mich im Bundestag erinnern kann
dass jemals so viel Gesetze auf den Weg
gebracht hat so viel Handeln geschafft
hat wie dieses
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium allein in
dieser Woche die Verstaatlichung zu jung
nicht paar übrigens für einen Preis der
für den Staat günstig ist das falsche
Wort aber auf jeden Fall nicht teurer
ist als er hätte sein können
die treuhandlösung jetzt auch für
Rosneft
die Fragen auch die wir jetzt klären
müssen im Strommarkt dass wir auf der
energieministerkonferenz eine schwierige
Aufgabe zu lösen haben nämlich einen
Eingriff in den Markt zu tätigen um die
Preise runterzukriegen die Hauptaufgabe
der Politik ist es nämlich die Preise
runterzukriegen und daran arbeiten wir
sehr intensiv durch den Ausbau der
lng-terminals beispielsweise durch
Maßnahmen im Marktdesign und ich hoffe
auch durch einen gemeinsamen
europäischen Einkauf bei Gasen der
Zukunft denn auch das würde uns helfen
ganz wesentlich ist jetzt aber auch dass
wir
ganz genau hinschauen auf die
Betroffenen in den Betrieben dass sie
nicht nur die Bäckereien das sind diese
rein das sind Lackierereien das sind
auch Metzgereien das sind viele kleine
auch mittlere manchmal auch größere
Betriebe die sehr stark zu leiden haben
unter diesen horrenten Energiekosten und
deswegen ist es notwendig und richtig
das Bundesminister Harbeck jetzt auch
einen Vorschlag unterbreitet für eine
Ausweitung des
energiekostendämpfungsprogramms auf alle
energieintensiven Betriebe auch eine
extra Stufe für kleine mittlere
Unternehmen einführt damit wir hier
gezielt Hilfe schaffen aber ich sage
Ihnen auch ganz deutlich das versprechen
was sie ja versuchen abzugeben und in
Bayern ist es ja besonders explizit
ausgelegt es gibt ja kein Land das so
stark abhängig ist im russischen Gas und
Öl wie Bayern aus eigener Verantwortung
das so viel Verantwortung abschiebt wie
das der bayerische Ministerpräsident tut
die Folgerung muss aber jetzt sein dass
wir auch nicht versprechen können wir
können alle Kosten abfedern das können
wir nicht es wird Verluste geben wir
werden in eine rezessive Phase kommen
mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit aber es
gibt dann eben auch das Licht am Ende
des Tunnels und das heißt wir
investieren jetzt in Energieeffizienz
wie investieren jetzt in die
kabelkontext zu difference wir geben
jetzt die sparenreize sie sagt dankbar
der Industrie dass sie bereits über 20
bis 30 Prozent an Gas eingespart hat das
muss jetzt auch für die Haushalte gelten
also wir haben eine schwierige Zeit wir
haben eine Krise und so sollten wir auch
mit dir umgehen und zum Schluss möchte
ich Ihnen noch kurz etwas berichten ich
hatte vor
drei Wochen die Gelegenheit ein ganzes
Wochenende zu verbringen mit sieben
Abgeordneten aus der Ukraine
und die Herausforderung dort jenseits
des Krieges der schrecklich ist uns und
jeden Tag beschäftigt sind ja auch
ökonomisch minus 30 bis 50 Prozent
Wirtschaftswachstum in Anführungszeichen
die Heiztemperatur in Kiew ist
garantiert bei 12 wenn überhaupt das Gas
da ist in Krake ist gar keine garantiert
das sind auch Verhältnismäßigkeiten die
wir uns immer wieder angucken müssen wir
tun alles was wir können hier im Land
aber es bleibt richtig die Sanktionen
gegen Russland ist bleibt richtig die
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine zu
liefern es bleibt richtig gemeinsam
europäisch zu handeln darauf kommt es
jetzt an in dieser Krise und deswegen
bitte ich Sie auch dass wir gemeinsam
handeln dieser Krise und uns nicht
spalten lassen vielen Dank
ja ähnlich wie Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck auch hier der Appell von
Dieter janitschek noch mal in der Krise
doch gemeinsam zu handeln auch bei
unterschiedlichen Ansätzen und Meinungen
hören wir mal was der Koalitionspartner
sagt Reinhard Huben für die FDP
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen
welche Debatte wir hätten hier
eigentlich hätten führen soll
Pleitewelle verhindern wirtschaftliche
und industrielle Substanz in ganz
Deutschland erhalten das war der
ursprungsstext für Ihre aktuelle Stunde
am Freitag werden sie noch einen
entsprechenden Antrag wenn sie nicht
kurzfristig wieder ändern einbringen
Bürgern und Unternehmen eine
energiepolitische Perspektive geben
Preise unter Kontrolle bringen
Insolvenzwelle verhindern eine ganze
Menge Wellen vielleicht mal so auch mal
was zur Donauwelle aber Spaß beiseite
meine Damen und Herren
wenn ich jetzt ihre Beiträge gehört habe
aus der Unionsfraktion muss ich sie
fragen meinen sie das eigentlich ernst
dass sie eigentlich in diesem beiden
aktuellen Stunden mit uns hier
debattieren wollen meinen sie das
wirklich im Ernst die Menschen sind in
Sorge sie haben wirklich Sorgen die
Menschen in Deutschland und dann wird
hier eine solche Debatte losgetreten ich
kann es ehrlich gesagt nicht verstehen
sie haben am 24.2 sie haben am 24.2
zugesagt bei bestimmten Fragen die
Regierung zu unterstützen wir begrüßen
das bei den Fragen der Verteidigung der
Freiheit in der Ukraine und insgesamt in
Europa aber dazu gehört natürlich auch
meine Damen und Herren dass wir die
Heimat das Land weiterhin im Auge
behalten und dazu gehört natürlich die
ganz entscheidende Aufgabe
Energiesicherheit in Deutschland
herzustellen
und
ersparen sie haben ja eine ganze Menge
Fragen gestellt vielleicht kann herr
Lenz dass der der ist ja noch mal dran
klären ersparen sie haben viele Fragen
gestellt der Minister war
der Minister war eine Stunde bei uns im
Wirtschaftsausschuss nach meiner
Kenntnis war ja auch im Ausschuss Klima
und Energie Herr stark ich habe sie im
Wirtschaftsausschuss vermisst ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben dort
einige Fragen gestellt die auch
beantwortet worden sind es wären
vielleicht manche Fragen nicht nötig
gewesen wenn sie sich wirklich
informiert hätten und meine Damen und
Herren die Ampelkoalition die
Ampelkoalition hat ja nun wirklich nicht
das schwere Erbe einer fatalen Energie
Abhängigkeit von Russland gerne geerbt
aber nehmen Sie bitte zur Kenntnis dass
wir neben den schon beschlossenen
Paketen 95 Milliarden weiterhin uns
darum kümmern dass wir eben Gas bekommen
und dazu gehört dann leider auch in
diesem Zusammenhang die Frage wie man
mit uniper umgeht
und sie alle gehen zu Veranstaltungen wo
regionale Energieversorger auf uns
Politik zukommt auf sie auch und sagen
ihr dürft uniper nicht kaputt gehen
lassen mein regionaler Energieversorger
die reinen Energie Köln sagt wenn
Juniper kaputt geht haben wir einen
Schaden mindestens von 300 Millionen
Euro
nein ich baue keinen grob als auch es
scheint sie ja zum stören Herr Merz wir
ich kann ja den Kollegen Falko Moos noch
mal mit ihren Formulierungen zum Thema
nordstream 1 wiederholen das brauchen
wir dann nicht ich halte sie für
intelligent genug dass sie wissen dass
sie damals nicht das richtige gesagt
haben also tun sie doch nicht so
und wie sie wissen genau meine Damen und
Herren wenn Juniper fällt und in
Insolvenz geht werden wir Probleme haben
mit der Gasversorgung weil dann
sämtliche Verträge die uniper
abgeschlossen hat nicht mehr faktisch
umsetzbar sind und deswegen ist es
sinnvoll das zu tun und glauben Sie mir
als fdp-ler ich freue mich auch nicht
darüber dass wir nun ein Unternehmen
verstaatlichen und ich freue mich auch
nicht darüber dass wir Atomkraftwerke in
Schweden nur auf einmal im Portfolio
haben sie könnten ja mal den Minister
fragen ob er den Juniper bekommen hätte
ohne die AKWs ich halte das für eine
relativ irrige Frage und meine Damen und
Herren dann kommt die Debatte die wir
führen müssen wie finanzieren wir es und
ich kann nur feststellen für die
Ampelkoalition dass man sich an dem
Wochenende wo man 22 Stunden
debattiert hat sich beraten hat dass man
auseinandergegangen ist dass eine
gasumlage eingeführt ist das ist für uns
zumindest Grundlage der Debatte und
deswegen sind wir gespannt auch
vernünftige Lösungen die der
Wirtschaftsminister einbringen wird und
eine letzte Bemerkung
wir haben auch ein Problem mit dem Strom
und deswegen sollten wir ernsthaft
überlegen die drei AKWs die wir noch
haben über den 31.12 laufen zu lassen
vielen Dank
ja kleinere Unterschiede gibt es da bei
den ampelkoalitionären
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber hier noch mal der kleine die kleine
Anmerkung von Reinhard Hohm von der FDP
zu den AKW Laufzeiten ich darf sie nur
darauf hinweisen tatsächlich dass wir
morgen hier im Bundestag auch einen
plenumstag haben wir in der sehr stark
geprägt von energiepolitischen Debatten
sein wird da wird es noch mal einen
Antrag der Union geben zum Verzicht auf
die gasumlage es wird ein Antrag der
Union geben die Laufzeit eine drei
verbliebenen Atomkraftwerke in
Deutschland zu verlängern eine Aktuelle
Stunde der Ampelkoalition zur
Energieversorgung und so weiter also
morgen das Thema Energie wirklich sehr
groß hier im Bundestag vertreten und
jetzt hören wir weiter in die aktuelle
Stunde bevor wir dann nach New York
schalten wenn US-Präsident beiden dort
mit seiner Rede vor der General vor der
unvollversammlung beginnt aber solange
noch hier natürlich
weiter in der Aktuellen Stunde mit
Andreas Lenz jetzt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion am Rednerpult so nicht
funktionieren
es ist so es ist so dass die gasumlage
einseitig Verbraucher belastet
insbesondere die Unternehmen das
Handwerk und den Mittelstand sie war ein
Schnellschuss der weder sozial gerecht
ist noch durchdacht noch sinnig
konstruiert ist morgen können Sie
entsprechend einen Antrag von uns
zustimmen wir fordern sie auf letzten
Endes dieses vermurkste Gesetz vom Tisch
zu nehmen
wie viele
wie viele Unstimmigkeiten es gibt das
zeigt jedoch auch die letzte
sonderausschusssitzung in der letzten
Woche da gab es keine Antworten auf sehr
sehr viele Fragen was ist die was ist
beispielsweise die Berechnungsgrundlage
der gasumlage wir wissen nicht wir
wissen nicht wie sich die 2,3 Cent gibt
pro Kilowattstunde zusammensetzen das
bleibt eine Rätsel übrigens ist 2,4 Cent
das ist fast genauso viel wie der
Gaspreis in den USA momentan getragen
und es beträgt übrigens einen
Familienhaushalt 600 Euro im Jahr ist es
klug es ist klug es ist klug auf der
einen Seite zu belasten und auf der
anderen Seite dann zu versuchen
Verbraucher aber keine aber keine
Unternehmen die Umsatzsteuer auf Gas zu
senken wie kann man Krebs tritt
verhindern also den Fakt dass
Unternehmen die gasumlage bekommen die
sie gar nicht brauchen keine Antwort im
Ausschuss in der ersten Fassung wäre die
gasumlage insgesamt 12 Unternehmen aus
dort wurden zwei übrigens zwei
Unternehmen mit Rekord gewinnen das ist
doch Wahnsinn wie wollen Sie dieses
Thema Relevanz der Unternehmen
definieren für die Unternehmen die die
gasumlage bekommen keine Antwort werden
sie werden außer uniper noch andere
Unternehmen das ist ja ein relevanter
Punkt die gasumlage brauchen oder wir
finden sich schon andere Unternehmen in
einer Schieflage Stichwort VNG keine
keine Antwort es drängt sich doch der
Verdacht auf dass sie überhaupt keine
Ahnung haben was sie hier überhaupt
wollen und wie sie diese Umlage
ausgestalten wollen und damit werden sie
im Moment ihrer Verantwortung in keiner
Weise gerecht
und mittlerweile sagt ja auch die FDP
und die SPD immer wieder das ist die
Umlage Robert habecks anfangs dieser
Woche hieß es noch habeg Zweifel selbst
an der gasumlage herzlichen Glückwunsch
er habe ich das machen wir schon lange
im August meinte habe ich übrigens noch
wörtlich die Alternative ist nicht keine
Umlage die Alternative wäre der
zusammenbrach Bruch des deutschen
Energiemarktes und damit weiter Teile
des europäischen Energiemarkts diese
Umlage ist die gerechtes möglichste Form
erklärte Harbeck damals weiter Herr
Habeck das ist nach Prüfung der Fakten
einfach falsch eine Rettung ist auch
ohne Umlage möglich und eine andere Form
der Rettung ist auch gerechter und auch
rechtssicherer es ist doch nicht richtig
wenn jetzt die Oma durch ihren
Gasverbrauch letzten Endes die Rettung
von uniper bezahlt das ist doch Realität
er stellt sich also die Frage was
bezüglich uniper übrigens auch die
Bundesregierung jetzt weiß was sie im
Juli noch nicht wusste oder noch nicht
WUs wissen konnte Ende Juli wollte der
Bund eine Minderheitsbeteiligung von 30
Prozent jetzt de facto eine gesamte
Übernahme fragen über Fragen Unternehmen
brauchen aber jetzt schnelle Hilfe keine
zusätzliche gasumlage die ihnen gerade
in der jetzigen Situation noch den
Todesstoß bringen könnte führen Sie
lieber einen Basistarif für Gas ein wie
das beispielsweise die Niederlande in
dieser Woche gemacht hat stimmen sie
gegen diese gasumlage sie haben jetzt
die Gelegenheit dazu dann ist das vom
Tisch und das ist auch letzten Endes
konstruktive Opposition Bereichen in die
Hand ja nach Lösungen zu suchen aber die
gasumlage ist wieder sinnig noch
durchdacht herzlichen Dank
Andreas Lenz war das für die
cdu/cs-fraktion ja die
Argumentationslinien sind glaube ich
doch sehr deutlich geworden in dieser
aktuellen Stunde
für die SPD noch mal Timon gremmels
so Herr Spahn ist scheinbar von seinen
Pressegespräch frau Präsidentin meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren Herr
Spahn ist scheinbar von seinen
Pressetermin zurückgekommen wir haben
jetzt der 20 Minuten die Debatte nicht
folgen können die sie selber hier
beantragt haben finde ich auch nicht
gerade ganz toller Stil genauso wenig
ersparen wie es ein guter Stil ist kein
guter Stil ist heute morgen weder im
Wirtschaftsausschuss noch im
klimaausschuss zu sein da hat sich Herr
Harbeck nämlich den Fragen gestellt und
all diese Fragen die Sie hier am Pult
gestellt haben hat er dort beantwortet
sie waren aber nicht dabei sie waren
nicht dabei und dann ich war im
klimaausschuss Frau Klöckner
selbstverständlich ja sehr schön aber er
hat es geht nicht dass sie Herr Spanier
hinstellt und sozusagen ein
nichtinformation beklagt die heute
morgen gegeben war aber warum haben Sie
das gemacht Herr Spahn weil im Ausschuss
waren keine Kameras und warum sie es
auch gemacht weil die ganze Inszenierung
von heute Nachmittag eben nicht
funktioniert hätte meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das ist Doppelmoral und
wissen Sie ja spannend bitte nicht
ein Buch veröffentlicht mit dem Titel
wir werden einander viel verzeihen
müssen das haben sie nicht diesen
Persilschein haben sie sich selber
ausgestellt in der corona-krise und
jetzt sozusagen dieses was Sie für sich
selbst in Anspruch nehmen anderen die
hart arbeiten die eine kriegerische
bewältigen die vermeintlich größer sein
und als die corona-krise eben dieses
Kriterium nicht zu Gute kommen zu lassen
das nenne ich Doppelmoral ersparen
schämen sie sich schämen sie sich
und ich sage Ihnen jetzt zehnmal lieber
dass ich Robert Habeck dafür sorgt dass
wir hier Gas bekommen als dass die Union
um Masken besorgt meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ja das müssen sie sich
anhören das gehört nämlich auch zur
Wahrheit dabei bei ihrer
Krisenbewältigung ist doch in erster
Linie darum dass die Kollegen die
Taschen voll gemacht haben ich nenne nur
die Namen nenne ich jetzt lieber nicht
die kennen sie alle selbst das war ihre
Art von Krisenbewältigung und da ist mir
zehnmal lieber dass wir uns hier um eine
ordentliche und eine schnelle Versorgung
kümmern von Gas und übrigens warum
machen wir denn das weil die Schubladen
und Konzepte leer waren von Peter
Altmaier wir hatten doch gar keine
gefüllten Speicher es gab keine
speicherstrategie es war doch alles leer
er hat zugelassen als
Bundeswirtschaftsminister das im letzten
Jahr die Speicher ausgelaufen sind und
nicht nachgefüllt worden da gab es eine
ressortverantwortung und die hieß Peter
Altmaier meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren und wo waren denn und wo waren
denn die die und wo waren die
lg-terminals einen g-terminals auch
nicht da da mussten wir uns darum
kümmern nach Regierungsübernahme dass
die kommen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren deswegen backen Sie doch
bitte hier kleine Brötchen und reden sie
von ihrer eigenen Verantwortung wir
handeln hier handeln
wir sorgen dafür dass auch gerade im
Osten Deutschlands die Unternehmen eine
Perspektive bekommen ich bin dem
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und Robert
Habeck sehr dankbar dass man jetzt hier
einen Weg gefunden hat mit PCK Schwedt
eine Zukunftsperspektive zu geben eine
Standortsicherung Investitionen in knapp
einer Milliarde eurohöhe eine
Zukunftssicherung die wir da auf den Weg
gebracht haben das sind die Signale die
die Menschen interessieren dass wir hier
den industriellen Wandel gestalten meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und das
macht diese Bundesregierung und das ist
auch gut so
und ich sage Ihnen auch noch mal die
Fragen nach der Ausstiegsstrategie aus
fossilen Energien das fragt die Union
was die Ausstiegsstrategie der
Bundesregierung aus fossilen
Energieträgern ist ich sage Ihnen was
unsere Strategie ist unsere Strategie
ist eine
ausbausstrategie für erneuerbare
Energien und da haben wir doch es viel
nachzuholen weil auch da haben sie
nichts hinbekommen sie haben blockiert
und gebremst ich nenne die Kühe die
Kollegen Pfeiffer Nüsslein und Co sie
haben doch den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien über Jahre hier gebremst wir
wären doch sehr viel weiter wir wären
doch sehr viel Energie unabhängiger wenn
wir dort nicht die Bremse an Union
hatten deswegen bei all dem was wir hier
diskutieren und wir haben schwierige
Diskussionen erwarte ich sozusagen von
einer Volkspartei wieder Union dass wir
auch ihren gesellschaftlichen Auftrag
bei der Bewältigung dieser Krise hilft
und hier kein billigen Populismus abhält
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
dass mein Wunsch ob der Wirklichkeit da
haben sie an dieser Woche noch eine ein
oder anderen Stelle die Möglichkeit dies
zu unter Beweis zu stellen vielen Dank
simon kremmels war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und jetzt hören wir den
letzten Redner in dieser aktuellen
Stunde das wird der Abgeordnete Mike
außendorf sein für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Union hat
ja das Thema der aktuellen Stunde
reduziert auf die Frage der Öl- und
gasanbeutung und die gasumlage da aber
diese Fragen ja alles schon umfänglich
vom Minister Habeck beantwortet worden
möchte ich die Gelegenheit nutzen den
Blick mal wieder ein bisschen zu weiten
auf die Folgen auf die Inflation und auf
die Maßnahmen die ergreifen müssen und
werden um Unternehmen in diesem Land
über den Winter zu helfen
zunächst mal sind wir uns einig der
Auslöser für diese Krise ist der
russische Angriffskrieg daraus reduziert
Öl und gasknappheit wir haben schon
vorher das Problem Fachkräftemangel
abgebrochene Lieferketten und das alles
zusammen hat zu einem nie da gewesenen
angebotsschock geführt das ganze mit der
fossilen Inflation wenn man dass man in
Zahlen fassen geschätzt eine mindestens
eine dreistellige Milliardensumme die
pro Jahr ins Ausland abwies für die
Beschaffung fossile Energien das Geld
fehlt hier und das wollen wir
langfristig hier rein und durch den
Umstieg auf die Erneuerbaren das heißt
nämlich auch gleichzeitig 100 Milliarden
oder mehr Wertschöpfung hier im Land und
für uns Leuchten der Politik
ich möchte auch noch mal darauf kommen
auf das oft beschworene gespens einer
lohnen Preisspirale das ist nämlich
nicht das eigentliche Problem was droht
im Gegenteil wir haben mal die
importierte Inflation und wenn wir jetzt
mit klugen Lohnsteigerungen im unteren
Sektor entgegenwirken dann können wir es
schaffen möglicherweise den drohenden
nachfrageschock abzuwenden denn das wäre
dann eine weitere Verschärfung der
Inflation und der Krise wenn wir beide
Sachen zusammen hätten nachfrageschock
und angebotsschock das wäre schwer
auszuhalten und deswegen muss man beides
miteinander betrachten
so wir begegnen wir also jetzt der Krise
zunächst mal wenn ich denke zurückdenke
an die Situation vor einigen Monaten da
haben wir noch ernsthafte Sorge gehabt
ob wir überhaupt durch den Winter kommen
mit mit Gas und Strom das haben wir
jetzt geschafft dank Minister Habeck und
des ganzen Hauses haben wir jetzt
Energie Sicherheit was die Versorgung
anbelangt dazu zunächst mal obersten
dank so wie geht's jetzt weiter als
nächstes muss höchste Priorität haben
nachdem man die Versorgung Sicherheit
geklärt haben die Energiepreise zu
senken fangen wir an beim Strom hier
haben wir die gigantische Aufgabe die
Versäumnisse gerade der CSU aufzuräumen
die insbesondere in Bayern den Ausbau
der Stromtrassen boykottiert hat und die
Windenergie blockiert hat so und dann
haben wir noch Sicherheitsprobleme in
denen von ihnen so favorisierten
Atomkraftwerken und da kann man sich
einfach nicht drauf verlassen auf das
was uns die CSU da präsentiert dann
müssen wir andere Wege beschreiben
so und wenn man jetzt über Preise reden
die Europäische Kommission arbeitet ja
schon in einem preisdeckel für Strom der
ja blöderweise großen Teils auch aus Gas
erzeugt wird und da haben wir eben die
Kombination
Gaspreis und Strompreis und diese
Kombination müssen wir aufheben und
darin arbeitet die Kommission und das
muss möglichst schnell gehen
zum Thema Gas wir haben das Angebot
verbessert das wird auch im Laufe des
Winters noch weiter noch besser werden
durch lng-terminals und wir stellen fest
dass sowohl VerbraucherInnen als auch
die Industrie nennenswerte Einsparungen
mit sich bringen und auch das hilft uns
über den Winter zu kommen und hilft auch
den Preis zu senken schwieriger ist es
beim Öl hier sind wir vom
weltmarktabhängig ihr hilft im Grunde
nur verbrauchssenken und das ganze ohne
Ideologie wenn wir mal auf das
Umweltbundesamt hören die sehen alleine
durch eine systematische
Geschwindigkeitsreduktion ein
Einsparpotenzial von mehr als zwei
Milliarden Litern Kraftstoff jährlich
so das waren die Preissenkung kommen wir
zur zweiten Priorität nämlich möglichst
zielgerichtete Entlastung nichts tun ist
keine Option das würde die Rezession
verstärken und dann müssen wir
gegensteuern wir müssen aber auch
ehrlich sein und keine falschen
Erwartungen wecken denn egal was wir tun
es wird am Ende in die Reichen keine
Entlastungspaket dass wir auf den Weg
bringen können wird am Ende dazu führen
dass alle Verluste ausgeglichen werden
das müssen wir uns immer wieder für
gegenwärtigen und den Menschen auch
offen sagen es geht darum existenzielle
Versorgung zu sichern und möglichst
viele Unternehmen das Überleben zu
ermöglichen so oder so wie das
Wohlstands Einbußen und Verluste geben
so das vorweggenommen wir werden in der
Bundesregierung zusammen mit dem
Ministerien und dem Parlament
verschiedene Wege beraten Ausweitung des
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogrammes auf
alle Branchen ist bereits schon im
Gespräch natürlich auch da werden immer
nur Spitzen weggenommen werden können es
wird nicht alle komplette Entlastung
geben können und es ist auch klar dass
möglicherweise zweistellige
Milliardenbeträge nicht aus dem normalen
Haushalt kommen und da ist natürlich der
Bundesfinanzminister auch gefragt
Einnahmequellen aufzuzeigen wie wir das
machen so insgesamt sind die Hilfen
nämlich eine gesamtstaatliche Aufgabe es
liegt nicht nur an dem Bundesminister
für Wirtschaft dafür zu sorgen dass wir
Entlastung schaffen sondern wenn wir uns
die Krankenhäuser ankommen ist auch das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium gefragt wir
alle hören in unseren Wahlkreisen
alarmierende Stimmen die von Kommunen
von Sportvereinen die ihre Sporthalle
nicht mehr betreiben können das können
wir nur im Schulterschluss mit den
Ländern lösen so da komme ich zum
Schluss noch mal auf die Union zurück
sie reagieren ja in einigen
Bundesländern mit das heißt sie stehen
in einer gesamtstaatlichen Verantwortung
sie können sich jetzt entscheiden sie
können weitermachen wie bisher
fundamentaloppositionen dass es einfach
sie können immer mehr fordern denn kein
Paket wäre groß genug und die
gegenfinanzierungsfrage offen lassen
können sie machen aber ich fordere Sie
auf lassen sie uns zusammen in
gemeinsamer Verantwortung mit den
Ländern und allen demokratischen
Fraktionen hier im Haus an zielgenauen
Lösungen zu arbeiten das ist es nämlich
was jemanden von uns in diesem Land
erwarten
der mike außendorf war das für die
Bündnis grünen hier letzte Redner in
dieser aktuellen Stunde
die hiermit beendet ist das ist ja
kurzfristig aufgesetzt worden hat sich
aus der Fragestunde heute heraus
entwickelt auf Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion dieses Thema werden wir
morgen hier im Plenum des Deutschen
Bundestages sind nochmal sehen denn dann
wird abgestimmt über einen Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion zur Abschaffung bzw zum
Verzicht der gasumlage ab 1 Oktober das
hat Robert Habeck heute noch mal
bestätigt soll die Gas und Lage ja
greifen
Deutschlands größter gasimporteur
verstaatlich wird es könnte dann noch
mal geprüft werden
aber da sind sich die ampelkoalitionäre
nicht ganz einiges es gibt
beispielsweise vom Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner von der FDP auch
andere Stimmen also das Thema das wird
hier weiter behandelt war ja heute auch
Thema in diversen bundestagsausschüssen
und wie gesagt steht morgen auch in
mehrererweise hier auf der Tagesordnung
des Deutschen Bundestages jetzt steht
auf der Tagesordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages dass wenn sie noch mal einen
Blick auf das Vorschaufenster in unserem
Programm werfen die Generaldebatte
Bundespräsidentin Vollversammlung in New
York hier läuft wir warten eigentlich
auf die Rede von US-Präsident beiden die
wir dann natürlich übertragen würden das
Thema was aber jetzt im Bundestag
debattiert wird das hängt zumindest
zusammen mit den Vereinten Nationen und
mit
UN-Generalsekretär gut der hatte nämlich
kurz vor dieser Generaldebatte in New
York zu einem un Bildungsgipfel
eingeladen und da geht es um die
Schulbildung weltweit um die
Grundbildung mit gerade unter Krisen und
langanhaltenden Konflikten leidet also
es sind die Kinder die weltweit
wir als Koalition
258 Millionen Kinder die weltweit keinen
Zugang zu Grundbildung haben dazu haben
die ampelkoalitionäre hier einen Antrag
vorgelegt und der ist jetzt Grundlage
dieser Debatte es spricht für die
SPD-Fraktion hier als erste Rednerin
Nadja stammer
richtige Kinderrecht besagt dass jedes
Kind die Möglichkeit haben muss eine
Schule zu besuchen der Besuch der Schule
darf nichts kosten und die Kinder müssen
dort anständig behandelt werden
mehr als 260 Millionen Kinder können
allerdings gar nicht selber entscheiden
ob sie Hausaufgaben cool finden oder
auch nicht sie gehen nämlich gar nicht
in die Schule besonders dramatisch sieht
dabei die Lage in Afrika aus laut der
Europäischen Investitionsbank sind
weniger als 20 Prozent der afrikanischen
Frauen je zur Schule gegangen die Hälfte
der Kinder weltweit besucht die weltweit
keine Schule besuchen lebt in Afrika das
sind rund 30 Millionen Jungen und
Mädchen aber auch in Asien und
Lateinamerika ist vielen Kindern der Weg
zur Bildung versperrt häufig befinden
sich die Schulen zu weit weg vom Wohnort
der Kinder oder es kostet Geld die es
sich die Eltern nicht leisten können und
tatsächlich haben viele Kinder auch
einfach keine Zeit für die Schule sie
müssen nämlich arbeiten und Geld
verdienen weil ihre Familien zu arm sind
Corona war hier ein negativer Verstärker
eins von drei Kindern hat während der
Pandemie überhaupt keine Form von
Bildung erhalten keine Bücher keine
Arbeitsblätter keine whatsapp-gruppe
kein Radioprogramm aufgrund von
Schulschließungen haben laut wild
Ernährungsprogramm im ersten Jahr der
Pandemie
370 Millionen der ärmsten Kinder der
Welt 39 Milliarden Mahlzeiten verpasst
mit Hilfe unseres Engagements in der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit sind wir
behandlungsfähig und setzen der
Bildungskrise im globalen Süden etwas
entgegen mit dem vorliegenden Antrag
stellen wir vier Schwerpunkte besonders
in den Fokus erstens der Zugang Bildung
muss für alle Kinder verfügbar sein auf
dem Land in der Stadt und wir
fokussieren uns auf die Bildung für
Mädchen deutschland rückt im Rahmen der
g7-präsidentschaft das Thema
Mädchenbildung und die Bedeutung von
Gender transformativen Bildungssystemen
in den Vordergrund
zweitens die Ganzheitlichkeit bei den
Bildungsprojekten wird ein viele Aspekte
umfassender Ansatz genutzt denn Schule
funktioniert nur wenn Sie auch ein Dach
hat wenn sie Strom hat und wenn es
ausreichend Lehrpersonal gibt
der Schutz Schulen sind mehr als Orte an
denen Wissen vermittelt wird es gibt
Essen es entsteht Gemeinschaft
außerhalb des eigenen Zuhauses da sind
Menschen die helfen können da ist ein
Ort zum spielen wenn Kinder zur Schule
gehen ist das wie eine schützende Kraft
in ihrem Leben
viertens die Zukunft Grundbildung ist
der Grundstein um Selbstbestimmung über
die eigene Zukunft zu erlangen
insbesondere für Mädchen werden die
Zukunftsaussichten deutlich verbessert
wenn Sie Zugang zu Bildung haben
durch den deutschen Beitrag an die
globale Bildungspartnerschaft GPI in
Höhe von 316 Millionen Euro bis
mindestens 2026 unterstützt das BMZ die
Stärkung von Bildungssystemen in bis zu
90 Partnerländern der Fokus liegt dabei
auf der Förderung von hochwertiger
Grundbildung in den ärmsten Ländern der
Welt die GPI hat seit ihrer Gründung
dazu beigetragen dass zusätzlich 160
Millionen Kinder die Schule besuchen
konnten mehr als die Hälfte davon sind
Mädchen und über die finanziellen
Zusagen an den Fond education kennort
Welt fördert das BMZ
Bildungsmöglichkeiten für Kinder und
Jugendliche in Notsituationen und
langanhaltenden Krisen ganz im Sinne der
bildungskoordination zwischen
humanitärer Hilfe und
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit mit der
mittelzusage von 200 Millionen Euro für
den Zeitraum 23 bis 26 durch
Bundesministerin Schulze am
internationalen Tag der Bildung Anfang
des Jahres ist Deutschland derzeit
größter Geber bei education cannot wait
und für Mitte Februar 23 ist erstmals
eine wiederauffüllungskonferenz geplant
und Deutschland ist dort mit ausrüst mit
Ausrichter dieser Konferenz das ist gut
richtig und wichtig so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Grundbildung ist essentiell für alle
Kinder wir arbeiten gemeinsam für eine
Verbesserung der Lebenssituation und der
Zukunftsaussichten von Kindern im
globalen Süden daher bitte ich Sie um
Zustimmung zu diesem Antrag
sagt hier Nadja Stamer zu dem Antrag den
hier die ampelfraktion vorgelegt haben
und jetzt gehen wir in die Aussprache
nächster hier am Rednerpult ist für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Wolfgang stefinger erst
Mitglied im Ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe Vertreter
der Regierungsfraktion liebe Kolleginnen
damals sie fordern in ihrem Antrag
zugegeben da viele sinnvolle Maßnahmen
um die Bildung im
Entwicklungsländern zu stärken und wir
sind uns ja auch einig dass der das
Bildung der Schlüssel zur
Hungerbekämpfung ist dass es der
Schlüssel zur Verbesserung von
Lebensgrundlagen ist und auch beim Thema
Familienplanung eine wichtige Rolle
spielt hinzu kommt dass die Bildung zu
einem höheren Wirtschaftswachstum führt
und auch zu einer besseren Gesundheit zu
weniger Konflikten und verbesserter
ökologischer Nachhaltigkeit das Gespräch
heute morgen dass wir im Ausschuss
hatten mit UNICEF und Save the Children
hat noch mal verdeutlicht welche
verteilen Auswirkungen auch gerade die
corona-pandemie auf den Bildungsbereich
hatte und hat die schulabschlussquoten
sinken massiv die globale Hunger und
Wirtschaftskrise für dazu das Mädchen
wieder vermehrt verheiratet werden und
die Schule abbrechen und viele Eltern
können auch das Schulgeld nicht mehr
bezahlen die Vertreter die heute morgen
da waren haben aber auch deutlich
gemacht wie verheerend für Kinder die
und wir verhären die Folgen für Kinder
und die Zukunftsfähigkeit in den Ländern
ist und vor allem auch was die geplanten
Kürzungen im Etat 2023 für diesen
Bereich bedeuten und daher liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
mit Verlaub wirkt Ihr Antrag auf mich so
als würden sie hier mit vollem Anlauf
und mit viel Getöse in ein Becken
springen aus dem Ihnen die
entwicklungsministerinnen und der
Finanzminister aber schon vor Wochen das
Wasser abgelassen haben
ich darf Sie daher wirklich mal fragen
mit welchen Haushaltsmitteln wollen Sie
denn all ihre Forderungen umsetzen erst
vor zwei Wochen haben wir hier an dieser
Stelle über den Etat debattiert und
waren uns auf fraktionsübergreifend ja
weitestgehend einig dass die Gelder hier
nicht ausreichen um die Krisen unserer
Zeit anzugehen
im Lichte der Haushaltsdebatte die wir
letzte die wir in der letzten
Sitzungswoche geführt haben wirkt mit
Verlaub ihr Antrag nicht wie ein Akt von
parlamentarischem Selbstbewusstsein
sondern eher wie ein Antrag fürs
Schaufenster sie haben nur leider
vergessen dass der Finanzminister die
Stromrechnung nicht bezahlt hat und der
Wirtschaftsminister bereits das Licht
abgedreht hat das ist die Realität
sie beschreiben also in ihrem Antrag was
sie gerne umsetzen würden wenn ihre
eigene Regierung sie nur ließe oder wie
kann man diesen Antrag ansonsten
verstehen interessant ist nämlich auch
wenn wir uns mal die Anträge der FDP und
der Grünen aus der letzten Wahlperiode
anschauen was sie da noch alles
gefordert haben die Grünen wollten in
ihrem Antrag auf Drucksache 19 456 noch
Kinder mit Behinderungen stärker
gefördert wissen davon lese ich in ihrem
Antrag überhaupt nichts die Grünen
wollten den Anteil für die globalen
Bildungspartnerschaften perspektivisch
auf 100 Millionen erhöhen die FDP in
ihrem Antrag auf Drucksache
1927-809 sogar auf 110 Millionen Euro in
ihrem jetzigen Antrag lese ich sie
begrüßen die Aufstockung der Mittel im
Rahmen der Haushaltsverhandlungen und
wollen den deutschen Beitrag zur
globalen Bildungspartnerschaft und zur
education kenote nachhaltig auf das
erforderliche Niveau heben ja was ist
denn jetzt ist erforderliche Niveau das
aus ihren Anträgen aus der letzten
Wahlperiode mit 110 bzw 100 Millionen
Euro oder das was sie vorgelegt haben im
Haushaltsentwurf die Kürzung auf 50
Millionen Euro also diese Frage sollten
Sie meines Erachtens schon einmal
beantworten ich darf Sie auch daran
erinnern dass sie die Mittel zum
Beispiel für UNICEF um 57% und insgesamt
für die globalen Bildungspartnerschaft
um 21 Prozent kürzen wollen die FDP im
übrigen forderte noch im März 2021 also
gar nicht so lange her dass im Rahmen
der Entwicklungszusammenarbeit das
privatwirtschaftliche Engagement in der
beruflichen Bildung in Entwicklungs- und
Schwellenländern wesentlich stärker zu
unterstützen sei und hierbei auch eine
bessere Verzahnung von
Ausbildungsmaßnahmen und
arbeitsplatzaufbau und Entwicklungs-
und das haben wir heute morgen auch in
der Anhörung gehört dass man nicht alles
mit öffentlichen Geldern regeln kann und
schon gar nicht wenn Sie diese kürzen
ist braucht also die Kooperationen mit
der Wirtschaft um Arbeit und
Ausbildungsplätze auch im globalen Süden
zu schaffen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen leider habe ich nicht
ausreichend Redezeit um noch weitere
Beispiele zu nennen weil es gäbe nämlich
schon nach ein paar schöne Schmankerl
die sie in den letzten Jahren hier
gebracht haben ich kann also nur aber
nur eines feststellen als
Opposition in den letzten Jahren waren
ihre Forderungen so groß im umsetzen ist
die Regierung so klein manchmal
manchmal ist es halt doch besser lieber
nicht zu regieren als falsch zu regieren
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun die Kollegin
Susanne Menge das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren lieber Kollege
stefinger ich bin erstaunt wie wenig sie
diesen Parlament zutrauen wir haben den
Haushalt noch gar nicht verabschiedet
und wir sitzen hier damit wir alle doch
gemeinsam für die guten Dinge und für
die guten Ziele kämpfen und das werden
wir im November entscheiden
let me learn lasst mich lernen das
forderten weltweit
jugendvertreter:innen und
jugendbotschafter innen am Wochenende
stellvertretend für ihre Generation beim
Bildungsgipfel der Vereinten Nationen in
New York bildung ist ein Menschenrecht
in der Realität ist sie jedoch ein
Privileg wir lassen viele Kinder und
Jugendliche dieser Welt nicht lernen
dieses in den SDG und der
Kinderrechtskonvention verankerte recht
bleibt ihnen verwehrt
bereits vor der corona-pandemie hatten
wir es mit einer Bildungskrise zu tun
denn rund die Hälfte der zehnjährigen
Kinder waren nicht in der Lage eine
einfache Geschichte zu lesen und sie
auch zu verstehen die meisten davon den
Ländern mit niedrigem und mittleren
Einkommen nach den jüngsten
Modellrechnungen von UNICEF und der
Weltbank sind es heute zwei Drittel der
zehnjährigen weltweit die keine einfache
Geschichte lesen und verstehen können ja
die Krisen der Welt überschlagen sich
aktuell der völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine die
dadurch ausgelügt der Hunger und
Energiekrise die corona-pandemie und die
Klimakrise aber in der breiten
Öffentlichkeit ist kaum die Rede von der
aktuellen Bildungskrise in unserer Welt
in Uganda endete Anfang Januar diesen
Jahres nach fast zwei Jahren die längste
Pandemie bedingte Schulschließung
weltweit
83 Wochen lang wurde fast 95 Prozent der
schüler:innen in Uganda ihr Recht auf
Bildung verwehrt nur Eltern der
restlichen fünf Prozent konnten den
alternativen distanzunterricht überhaupt
finanzieren
internationalen schätzungen zufolge sind
30 Prozent der Kinder und Jugendlichen
insbesondere Mädchen und Jungen nicht
mehr in die Schulen zurückgekehrt viele
Mädchen wurden schwanger oder wurden
früh zwangsverheiratet andere Kinder
müssen arbeiten weil die Eltern den Job
verloren haben oder das Schulgeld nicht
mehr bezahlen können Lehrkräfte haben
ihren Arbeitsplatz gewechselt weil sie
über einen Zeitraum von zwei Jahren
nicht arbeiten konnten diese Entwicklung
alarmieren daher bringen wir hier heute
gemeinsam mit der SPD und der FDP
unseren Antrag zur Grundbildung im
globalen Süden ein
denn das Recht auf Bildung darf kein
Privileg bleiben Grundbildung das heißt
beispielsweise in der Lage zu sein lesen
und schreiben zu können und die
Grundrechenarten zu beherrschen mit
einer Grundbildung geben wir Kindern
kulturhandwerkszeug an die Hände wir
legen damit Grundsteine dafür dass
eigene Potenzial auszuschöpfen
Grundbildung bereitet den Weg für eine
existenzsichernde Ausbildung und Arbeit
Grundbildung bedeutet zukunftsfähige
Perspektiven zu entwickeln sie hilft
Macht und Herrschaft zu verstehen
Argumente zu finden und Lösungen aus
schwierigen Situationen zu entwickeln
Grundbildung erhöht die Chance auf ein
selbstbestimmtes Leben
und ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass
Grundbildung und die Bildungsinhalte die
wir vermitteln heute wichtiger denn je
sind wenn wir demokratiebildung wollen
und wenn wir demokratiebildung weltweit
wollen
bildung ist ein öffentliches Gut und
Bildungsorte müssen schutzorte sein die
Staaten dieser Welt müssen ihrer
Verantwortung nachkommen und Bildung für
ihre Gesellschaften bestmöglich
bereitstellen wie aber soll ein Staat
Veganer zum Beispiel der 46% seiner
öffentlichen Einnahmen zur Schwerte zu
sparen wir gehen ganz schnell nach New
York dort spricht jetzt US-Präsident
beiden vor der unvollversammlung
Insolvenzverfahren darauf arbeiten wir
hin so wie im Koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten
stattdessen wurde nun beim un
Bildungsgipfel eine neue Finanzierungs